entre bébé mutilé et maisons incendié
c'est un véritable massacre que le Hamas
a laissé derrière lui dans les kibuts
proche de la frontière de Gaza 4 jours
après le début des attaques terroristes
du Hamas en Israël les soldats de
l'armée israélienne et les journalistes
internationaux ont découvert l'horreur
qui a frappé samedi 7 octobre au petit
matin les kibuts de karaza Berry
kisoufim et Niro en Israël à quelques
kilomètres de la frontière de la bande
de Gaza qui ont été envahis par le Hamas
selon tal l'armée israélienne 70 membres
du Hamas auraient envahi karaza Omer
Barak un officier israélien de 24 ans
raconte que les Palestiniens les ont
incendiés pour forcer leurs occupants à
sortir et ensuite les mitrailler pour
galid danjaou une franco-israélienne qui
vivait dans l'un de ses kibuts une seule
certitude sa mère Carmela 80 ans et sa
fille noya 13 ans sont h Tage du Hamas
elles ont été enlevées samedi matin à
nirose samedi matin peu avant 7h il y a
eu l'alerte couleur rouge quand elle
sonne les habitants ont 20 secondes pour
se mettre à l'abri avant l'explosion de
la Roquette en général il y a un bou et
on ressort sauf que cette fois c'était
un vrai bombardement ça n'arrêtait pas
et puis on a entendu des tir d'armes
automatiques alors on a compris que des
terroristes étaient rentrés à pied dans
le kibbots j'ai entendu quelqu'un
rentrer chez moi il parlait arabe il a
essayé d'ouvrir la porte du bunker mais
il n'a pas réussi ensuite je l'ai
entendu tirer depuis ma maison vers les
soldats j'ai pris mon téléphone portable
j'ai dit à maman d'aller vite se mettre
à l'abri et là je me suis souvenu qu'à
nirod il n'y a pas de barre de fer pour
fermer les abris de l'intérieur vers
midi sa fille lui envoie un message
vocal j'entends des gens maman c'est le
dernier qu'elle a reçu j'étais coupé du
monde il n'y avait plus d'électricité
plus de wifi et à 3h du matin elle est
exfiltrée par les soldats israéliens
pendant la journée j'essaie de ne rien
ressentir pour pouvoir vivre car
autrement je meurs la nuit je ne dors
pas je n'arrête pas de penser à elle je
ne peux pas imaginer dans quelles
conditions elles vivent où ils les
gardent qu'est-ce qu'elles reçoivent à
manger je ne sais rien les témoignages
comme celui-ci se multiplie depuis la
reprise des kibuts par l'armée
israélienne selon elle 40 bébés auraient
été assassinés par les assaillants du
Hamas dans ses kibuts libérés certains
d'entre eux même décapité plusieurs
militaires israéliens interrogés par la
FP font état de plus de 100 morts
civiles parfois 150 le Premier ministre
israélien Benjamin netanahou a annoncé
lui lundi soir qu'une attaque massive se
préparait en guise de
représaille